didn't you just tell us what the title
was 40 seconds ago yeah you did is this
movie for the 4/20 crowd brother and two
cops are dead because of me I'm not
looking for a second chance but I'm not
the only one with a death sentence my
wow that's a ton of awkward exposition
jammed into one line of dialogue waiting
this mission is a quick edit out
something we surely discussed before
running into the middle of a war zone
but I'm reminding you of now just in
case there are secret people watching
this on a screen we don't know about
objective located there's something else
you have to say well it's not exact but
you better come take a look at this
cliche Jesus dude not only is that order
unnecessary since you just gave it but
shouldn't the first thing you're
thinking be something is wrong rather
than those not answering jag-offs are
being insubordinate he's been through a
lot sure but still
Connor survives this half a terminator
somehow reaches up to six-foot John
shoulder while lying prostrate on the
ground and decides that's a scariest if
not most efficient way to attack him
t600 officially dies in dramatic fashion
as John walks over its body Marcus who
was in some sort of robot cryo sleep and
who was definitely down in that bunker
where all of John Connor soldier buddies
just got completely wiped out is alive
and only suffered uncleanliness oh and
what do we have here a dead guy who
wears my exact size man this is the
luckiest day ever
futuristic rain somehow completely clean
Marcus of that muddy afterbirth that was
on him just a couple seconds ago movie
rips off the perfect storm from the
perfect storm before it even has a
chance to rip off the guy desperate to
reach submarine jumps off chopper with
no guarantee of rescue thing from The
Hunt for Red October
yeah resistance command headquarters in
a submersible which I'm sure the
machines have no way of tracking
whatsoever right what did we find down
there you'll be brief doesn't need to
know business excuse me what what
possible reason could this guy be
withholding information from John in the
post apocalyptic war against the
machines it's not like John can be a
double agent in this scenario leaking
information to Skynet what did we find
out we found a solution corner
that kid head this war once and for all
and just because I started talking the
screens behind me will somehow know to
display information important to this
discussion does it work
will it work yes everybody feel tested
it no um how do you know it work if you
haven't even tested Oh are these people
you ever hear of an establishing shot
damn surprise committee is surprised I
mean if you go back you can see the
Asian dudes face in the background but a
whole committee car we do this road Wars
this guy literally went from you
jeopardized everything Punk to the job
as your son in like 67 seconds a kill
list was intercepted from Skynet it says
everyone in this room will be dead
Skynet bothers to make a kill list the
purpose of which can only function to be
intercepted by human spies why make a
kill list when your purpose is to simply
kill all humans anyway well who's number
one and unknown a civilian Kyle Reese
role cred Oh I mean dump dump dump also
both in 2018 Skynet cannot possibly know
the importance of Kyle Reese and can't
possibly think he's more dangerous than
John Connor unless for some reason they
have records of calories from 1984 and
then we start talking about time
paradoxes how our rebellion air strips
even temporary ones able to set up an
artery without the machines coming in
and nuking everything right you did know
he totally made it and see he noticed
this in a barren wasteland because the
script tipped him off but then the
Terminator it was tape 7 tape 7 November
10 and Sarah didn't say these exact
things in this exact way hey man they're
tapes they don't suddenly record
different than you put into him also
boy that's a number 28 it affect your
decision to send people murmuring the
lies you thought what to tell you and
what not to don't clear caller you can
never will in fact your decision that a
pair psycho crazy thinking about this
also how did the picture from the first
Terminator get zoomed in slightly from
the original the world is a fascinating
place street urchin ex machina
it's not a Terminator movie unless one
of the machines steps on a skull somehow
this machine has the same terrible aim
that regular human bad guys have idiot
kids somehow still alive invented a
terminator trap that traps terminators
but keeps them completely alive and can
still shoot you
if you want to Lin movie is more
interested in callbacks to previous
better films in the franchise than it is
in establishing its own awesomeness you
mean they have something set up to fall
exactly on this place where this
Terminator just so happens to be right
now also uh terminators so advanced you
can completely incapacitate them with a
half-assed booby trap kick it off
amazing soldier Kyle Reese allows Marcus
to continue walking towards him in an
obvious ploy to steal his gun without
firing a shot or backing up what
happened Judgment Day
man Jesus are you a robot why does this
building collapse
did the 8k do something to it they can
do this why didn't it destroy all the
buildings grab it
I was the purpose of that so he can't
take the weapon big deal is that
supposed to help him against the
terminators isn't simply not being in
range to have your weapon taken also a
good technique coming over in one of
these seven earned mine yet yet I am
still the most wanted man on the Skynet
kill list Oh Connor broadcasts this
desperate message on the very night
Marcus is fixing Kyle's radio terminated
her convenience identity you man's want
them eradicated but are generally pretty
casual about the whole affair as opposed
to creating however many terminators it
takes to find and kill all the humans
they prefer to keep things competitive
are there radio stations still playing
music after the apocalypse and if that's
a CD it definitely wouldn't have started
playing like that and a cassette would
definitely be dead by now
I've never driven before how did you
even get this far then luckiest tire
iron throw ever also disables the Scout
immediately like it's made of paper the
idea is to stay alive I'm driving
Marcus is a dick also first off you had
no choice but the let Kyle drive into
the circumstances second off he just
told you he's never driven before and
obviously didn't want the job so what
the was that
yeah just park that Jeep anywhere
asshole it's not like a Scout made note
of what you're driving and what you look
like or anything wait he has a gun which
means they had a gun during the chase
with the Scout a minute ago so why did
Marcus need to throw a tire iron at that
thing earlier I want to give this kid
points for spotting this recently
falling milk drop clue but honestly a
much more inclined to send a movie for
allowing someone to take a guzzle of
this cream milk but still somehow get
away and hide before the last milk
bottle dropped balls how does a giant
machine like this managed to make zero
noise until it's time to blindly start
grabbing people machines have these
things at their disposal but keep
sending back humanoid terminators
because they must not really want John
Connor dead I guess Jesus this thing is
terrifying
Skynet's main goal is to end humanity
but they're taking prisoners is this so
it wouldn't seem stupid that the giant
robot didn't just blow up the 7-eleven
while I had the chance
giant murder bot which was able to
blindly grab a person hiding in a garage
is unable to detect the large gas tanker
headed its way and doesn't blast it to
smithereens
honestly I'm shocked these robots
weren't able to win the war here in the
future which enable all these movies in
the first place
they look basically indestructible also
of course he'd have motive terminators
that come out of his legs he probably
also has the dogs with the bees in their
mouths so that when they bark they
should be zit you here's a weird aspect
of Terminator Salvation we know Kyle
can't done it because he has to go back
in time before John the only person who
can change his predestined course he
hasn't even met yet so any danger Kyle
is in his mutiny scenes well Jesus man
why the didn't this thing just blow them
away in the first place instead of the
giant sending motor terminators to do
the job number one priority target Kyle
Reese is simply thrown into a jail are
they saving him for Baltimore to kill
and why did they spend all that time
trying to kill him before and why are
they trying to kill Marcus if they're
taking the others prisoner is it because
they needed to save Kyle and Starr from
falling out of the sky because they're
important to the plot all I'm saying is
this prisoner is fucking confusing each
decision these robots make ant me
earlier when Marcus and crew blew at the
7-eleven and they thought they blew up
the robot we'll find out later nope the
robot is pretty unbelievable
and obviously the prisoners holding bin
is too because damn that was a huge
explosion so now it's really strange
that if it's like indestructible metal
an axe can somehow launch into this
thing and prevent Marcus from falling
and dying giant robot slams Marcus down
into hard metal from several stories up
and doesn't crush him and yes I know
he's a Cyberdyne robot but this is more
than enough to crush his ass they've
never come this deep before they're
looking for something this statement
makes it sound like the humans are not
only holding their own but dominating
this war if the machines are too scared
to come too far inland j-- great is
that even possible
evasive maneuvers now this order comes
10 seconds too late for the pilot who
just died it's got a lock on you break
off seems like the kind of sloppy
dialogue someone might write who doesn't
know how signal walkie works well it
sure looks like a machine city in the
distance here which means this line
about the machines not wandering this
far inland is even more interesting
given that they are setting up shop
literally 1.5 miles from inland Shaima
crater wash what the fade to black
is this a goddamn TV show that is the
most commercial break like moment I have
ever seen in a movie Jesus but gee
should I sure that's really important
right now can he really not grab her and
get her on some solid footing before she
drops 20 feet to the ground and yet
again a movie suggests that a person can
grab another person in midair like this
without that person also falling or at
the very least pulling someone's arm out
of socket what are you saying
speak English that's racist they're
gonna kill us they're gonna kill
everyone it actually doesn't matter
whether they aren't killing everyone the
prisoner is ridiculous but especially if
they end up killing these people anyway
the most important thing that we can do
right now is stay alive what that's
happening with or without your input at
this point the most important thing you
can do right now is try to escape or at
the very least divvy up the cigarette
slipped aboard this thing so everyone
has an even amount mysterious chick
since Marcus out to find something that
can burn in a fucking monsoon what he
got there of course the one place they
decide to camp for the night has random
asshole Book of Eli people living here
so she attacks this first guy and guy
behind her descends to Russia for
hand-to-hand combat instead of shooting
her smart god knows what this third guy
squatting on the ground is doing seeing
this nice cozy bonfire makes me wonder
do the machines not send out scouts
every night looking for human fires
seems like that'd be a pretty easy way
to take out your adversary oh then why
did you lay out a perfectly good tarp
and pin it down with a log just to sit
on as opposed to making a tent blanket
or any other more sensible device out of
it also um sit closer to the fire that's
great but didn't you just intentionally
draw the machines here with an explosion
how does it floating that ship not draw
more machine ships works man signal
works it's beautiful yeah it works are
you suspicious yet what is the
extraction plan for the prisoners bond
there is no extraction plan we're going
to level the place even though we find
out later this signal is a Skynet ruse
why don't they plan to disable the
machines take the prisoners out and
blow up the place negative I told you
Skynet central is filled with human
prisoners which makes zero sense but
whatever hello the machines can't even
detect heat signatures from moving
vehicles honestly not sure the machines
deserved to win this war they seem
terribly inept at discovering and
killing however a few humans remain
after the global nuclear war we're about
to find out that Marcos is actually a
Cyberdyne robot that is practically
human but why this mine doesn't
absolutely destroy him only screenwriter
knows Marcos nearly dies so it's time
for a murky flashback because we love
seeing things that barely tell the story
while also making us set up an
appointment to our eye doctors Barnes do
you think when she said Barnes she meant
hit him in the head with the butt of
your rifle and if this guy's a robot
would it really perform the same task as
it does to movie humans because you know
a real human is dying from that no you
try killing my mother Sarah Connor you
kill my father Kyle Reese I'm saying my
parents names out loud because I'm angry
damn it and plus sometimes but not all
the time maybe somebody who has
information pertinent to the plot so
what saved Kyle Reese sonic transporter
heading for Skynet I don't know for a
fact that it's the same Kyle Reese and
the fact that you call that kid your dad
is really weird to me but cut man no
time to ponder I know everything you're
talking about because I too saw all
three terminators it saved my life
John Connor is asking himself why didn't
I find a way to tell myself this in the
other movies man I hate being
incarcerated and what's this something
that's going to help me get out of here
lying around in the open more no Barnes
falls for this girl's obvious fake
Connor wants to see you a story like a
chunk because the script wants markets
to be both easily captured and allowed
to easily escape logic does not exist in
this dojo yes sensei
watching unnecessary orders Lissa this
is you in this giant complex no one uses
radios to communicate I have all sorts
of technology in this place and you have
to travel to talk to somebody this is
the only way Blair's ruse works part way
through this minefield escape everyone
involved in the making of this movie
forgot that it was a minefield and it
just became a field escape yeah she did
the thing and blew a few of them up but
nowhere near all of them now I'm just
going by what I see in this helicopter
pursuit of Marcus I think I now
understand why the humans have yet to
overthrow the machines storm trooper aim
after 324 bullets John finally runs out
has to change guns I would write
something about him sacrificing himself
to save John thereby proving his
worthiness to the cause and propelling
the plot but honestly I'm much more
concerned with how he got here that
quickly without anyone noticing I can
get you in how look at me yeah but you
don't know any of the Skynet protocols
you just now learned you're a robot what
exactly you're expecting to happen here
is a find who did this to me uh you mean
AI and general or all the machines
there's not like a single entity I mean
surely you know this already right
you're telling me the resistance has
this kind of operation yet the machines
aren't able to find it track it or
exploded the machines deserve to lose
this war they really really suck Skynet
has Kyle Reese none of these guys even
know who Kyle Reese is as John shared
the story of his improbable birth to
everyone else and do they believe it
because I'm just putting myself in the
shoes of someone who has never heard
this story before and I'm thinking man
that's the craziest story one of my top
men could ever tell me over the radio
before we attack Skynet you are no
longer a part of this resistance I
didn't kiss the team either did I
soldiers disobey orders to still follow
soldier recently relieved of command
because of his obvious moral rightness
cliche how is he broadcasting to all
soldiers without command hearing this
and cutting in my own can forget it
if even one bomb drops on Skynet before
sunrise our future will be lost
sorry if I'm being a big bastard but I
don't have time to give you the details
of why that statement is true what
should I tell your men when they find
out you're gone I'll be back and also
we're gonna need a bigger boat no no
wait tell them the flux capacitor makes
time travel possible they'll understand
moto Terminator somehow doesn't see this
obvious trap are all these cars supposed
to have been abandoned during the
nuclear holocaust because if so why are
they also still intact shouldn't they be
charred
or were these cars all abandoned on this
remote ass Highway because of some other
reason or did the director just think
the shot would look cooler with a bunch
of abandoned cars on the side of the
road maybe the Golden Gate Bridge
finally succumbed to Skynet after being
mercilessly attacked by Apes hulks
Godzilla's x-men and San Franciscans
Skynet RSS feed I mean Skynet is a
self-aware computer system the power of
servers all over the world making it
essentially one giant living organism
and it's security is overridden by a
gameboy and yeah this is all the ruse to
get John Connor in here but why are they
wasting their time allowing him to do
all this instead of just blowing them
away right now
east observant terminator ever we knew
you'd be back after all it was
programmed in you oh what the only
reason why he came back is so he could
save calories for John Connor he didn't
have any particular predestined draw to
this place until the plot kicked in to
achieve but no other machine is achieved
before to infiltrate find a target and
then bring that target back home to us
admittedly this sounds downright
Machiavellian however think about how
this was achieved it was all dumb luck
he didn't have any intuition about what
he needed to do and who he needed to
meet it was more serendipitous than the
movie serendipity in fact let's take a
moment to talk about Skynet's plan they
build a machine with human tissue that
looks human but they give it no
objective or even memory then drop it
off in the middle of nowhere and hope
that the humans find him and take him in
then they assume said machine would have
a conscience help the humans and that
he'd help them get into Skynet and send
a signal for John to come join them all
so that they can kill John instead of
just programming him to do that very
thing you did what Skynet has failed to
do for so many years you killed John
Connor the problem with this movie is we
have no idea what John Connors done yet
at this point he's merely a well
regarded subordinate in the resistance
he has a radio broadcast that while
important hasn't turned the tide yet in
this war still Skynet perceives John
Connor as if they know the events of the
last three Terminator movies something
they cannot know a little bit of
background on what this movie's timeline
knows and doesn't know would have helped
especially since John is our main
character and knows the entire story
hello a lazy narration read along would
have sufficed but we spent so much time
on Marcus the movie didn't have time to
do that the lighting in this building
really keeps everything pg-13 hahaha
CG Arnold is worse than that Angley Hulk
bullsh this was a super long con by the
machines but they still like suspense
enough to toy with John Connor instead
of killing why is this chip so easy for
him to access Plus Skynet allows him to
do this because they figure they've won
anyway but in Terminator 3 they were
killing any threat to their existence
and it's amazing they turn into arrogant
comic book super villains in this one
and don't simply turn them off or some
jerk
so many oh and yep they'll only send one
of them back to kill the man they hate
so much also it's a wonder any humans
are still alive after this no it
wouldn't be a climax of a Terminator
film without the hero fighting one of
the robots in some sort of factory with
flames all around it you know we saw the
earlier - six hundreds being born
basically with guns ready but none of
the t800 czar it's not like they're
going to send all of them back in time
so why is that plus so many fiery places
to throw John it decides to phone it in
and go with the I've got you so now I'm
going to randomly throw you somewhere
plan oh yeah I'm sure you totally knew
exactly where this fight was taking
place to dramatically jump down into it
right now plus the Terminator is somehow
not breaking John's neck something it
has the power to do in seconds but
decides not to do remind me again why is
there only one of these things in a
factory devoted to making these things
chasing after John once again terminator
doesn't seal the deal with another robot
it's fighting it decides not to throw
Markus into the molten steel just to be
sure
the Skynet really not have air defense
systems at their main base the
resistance makes this look easy
somehow this Terminator is still going
despite the fact that 1990s era molten
metal killed both a t800 and a t-1000
guess this molten metal here in this
movie just isn't hot enough oh wow good
thing these pipes shoot coolant that can
definitely stop a terminator in its
tracks if you happen to be in this very
situation
homemade AED you were stabbed through
the heart can you believe that without
knowing if they're in the clear John
goes ahead and presses the button causes
a massive explosion that could easily
have killed everyone in this helicopter
I guess that's it then no more movies
necessary Skynet's dead it's over
alright right this heart can take I just
so happen to have that very thing so I
can donate it to it take my heart
transplant surgery is probably pretty
easy out here in the desert wasteland
tent so what is it that makes us human I
don't know but I have a feeling this
narration is going to say it perfectly
are you professional or not do I can
walk around and rip that no shut the cup
Bruce do I want no no don't shut me up
what don't you fucking understand oh
good for you
kill caries reset the future
no junk are which happens dad's lead no
need to be a pussy you better here's
what I need it's not who I am underneath
but what I do that defines
so we don't know what this message means
our target package could have changed
you repeat this order I'll find somebody
who will
okay what's gonna happen to him
disassembled No
what are you I'm Batman I love you
I know